loneliness
causes a great increase in mortality 58
more likely to die if you live alone and
have no relationships to anybody
so even getting a dog or a cat is very
very useful in prolonging your life you
are the one who owns your body only you
can control what happens in your body so
dr bob is telling us to have more sex
yes
dr bob in the house he is uh the author
of a new book called immunity strong
how to boost your natural healing power
and live to
a hundred
welcome aboard man thank you nice to be
with you i've been actually diving in
very heavily on on the life extension
theme
taking challenges learning as much as i
can and what i loved about what you're
doing is a lot of the advice and the
life extension is basically there's so
much stuff coming in the next 15 or 20
years like so much just radical innova
innovation coming that your job as a
human is basically just don't die in the
next 15 to 20 years
just just stay alive because there's so
much great things coming right and
that's right
and what you're working on is
interesting because that's basically
giving giving the
the answers like hey here's how you can
stay alive and maybe not just stay alive
but thrive um you know not just in the
next 15 20 years but beyond i guess
depending on how old people are watching
so
what are some of the big levers that
people can pull right now in order to
boost their natural healing
well
right now there is a great connection
and i talk about it in my book between
love or companionship and boosting the
immune system we know with the pandemic
that loneliness
causes a great increase in mortality 58
more likely to die if you live alone and
have no relationships to anybody so even
getting a dog or a cat
is very very useful in prolonging your
life now people say well that's a little
nutty but as a physician i see it all
the time and physiologically here's the
thing there is something called emotion
which affects the brain's function and
the brain really controls immune
function
so there's such a thing as mind body and
soul
we've heard that over and over again now
i'm not one of those nutty doctors that
prescribes things like you know
soybeans
to take every night before you go to bed
etc i'm not one of those guys i'm a real
clinical person who takes care of people
with autoimmune and rheumatic diseases
but i'm also an immunologist so we find
that um
studying things like pregnancy for
example and looking at companionship and
neurohormonal activity that means
hormones that come from both the brain
and affect the rest of the body and most
importantly the immune system which i
call the biological soul so if you're
not a spiritual person you don't believe
in religion you can still believe that
inside of you you have a biological soul
which controls how your immune system
works and the immune system which
pervades every organ of the body if you
keep it healthy and robust
robust with good nutrition a normal
biome or organisms that live in your
bowel and a lot of your viewers know
this they take prebiotics and probiotics
if you control that and you have a
healthy lovemaking or companionship you
have a partner or husband or wife
where you can be very very intimate
that raises several things neuro
hormones like oxytocin called the love
hormone and the other is prolactin which
is the suckling hormone on a woman's
breast for example when a baby sucks the
breast after birth they produce high
levels of prolactin well guess what
prolactin increases as does oxytocin
when you hug and kiss your partner it
can be a man or a woman uh or you hug
and kiss your grandchildren or you hug
and chris your neighbor uh you enhance
immune function we've shown that t and b
cell function increases that the levels
of antibody neutralizing antibody
increase all of these things really are
a natural response to a normal feeling
in this case companionship and love
so i i've written a great deal about
this in various guises i'm very
interested in gender i'm very interested
in biological sex neuro hormones neuro
immuno endocrinology that's what we call
it big terminology
it means studying the brain the immune
system and the glandular system or the
endocrine system so this is all very
important and you do this properly
with vitamin c vitamin d
things like zinc
and other multivitamins like selenium
and
just now i was talking about magnesium
to another patient you will enhance your
immune function and live beyond a
hundred and that's why we're seeing that
because the gen z's know how to do that
now the gen z generation is exercising
they're doing yoga they're meditating
they're doing all the things that
affects us internally
you are the one who owns your body only
you can control what happens in your
body
i love it so dr bob is telling us to
have more sex
yes
i am i'm saying that sex we've always
known this but sex is really good for
you it really does and not just because
it makes you feel good but it has a lot
to do with companionship and it has a
lot to do with
immunoendocrine effects on your body
your skin your various organs like your
heart your blood pressure and
vasculature and all of the glands that
respond to the pituitary that's up in
your brain that really uh affect and
secrete a number of hormones that make
you younger
i love it i mean that that'd be that'd
be a fun thing to write on your
prescription pad when you're giving it
to your patient you know you don't need
a pill just go home and have more sex
that's right that's right so the book
subtitle is is
boost your natural healing power and
live to a hundred yes how
feasible is it for the average person
you think to get to a hundred i mean
it's definitely not an average age for i
don't know what the average age right
now is for people but like if you get
100 you're you're really you're in the
top percent of the percent
so yes
when do you think we can actually get to
100 being
a default age it's not like crazy old
but maybe an average age for people are
passing we're getting there we have more
centenarians in this country and in
europe and in the far east there are
many many centenarians those are people
who are 100 years of age and why is that
it's that is because they are adhering
to good diets and people are exercising
more and i have to tell you exercise
even though it sounds trite and it
sounds like a cliche it's extremely
important to be active i have conditions
that i see like chronic pain conditions
chronic fatigue syndrome
fibromyalgia which is largely in young
women
and i prescribe aerobic exercises for
them if they go to the gym
aerobic meaning running
meaning swimming
or even walking a half a mile to a mile
a day alleviates the pain syndromes that
they suffer so we have hundreds of
thousands of people that i'm predicting
will live beyond 100 going forward just
in the united states now in canada i'm
sure the lifestyle is very similar to
what we have in the u.s so they're
seeing in your country also an increase
in the number of centenarians and that's
not accidental the longer the lifespan
and these are all because of
improvements we've made in physiology
and in taking care of people who are
sick over the past hundred years so you
know back in 1930 the median age was 45.
so you were dead by the time you were
50. now
we can be way beyond a hundred and
probably i predict in the next 50 years
people will be living beyond 110 and
maybe even to 120 and they'd be in good
health because as we always say age is
just a number right yeah i mean my my
grandmother passed at the end of last
year
and she was you know in her late 90s so
i mean long long time ago yes um so
there's some hopefully some good genes
in there for me
yeah
but you know the last
decade of her life was not
super pretty you know it was like this
slow decline and so i think as
and a lot of people probably have some
kind of story like that in their family
as well just that hits me recently yeah
how do we
ensure not just length but also quality
of length
well quality of life comes you know
we're we're all going to get old and
we're many of us will die at a young age
many of beyond a hundred as i predict
now if you keep your diet your biome the
biome is extremely important and i go
into it in great detail in the book and
this is something that to be honest with
you i never adhered to earlier but when
i got to study the biomes of various
people for example people who were
depressed people who had schizophrenia
people who are autistic the biomes vary
in that population i'm talking about the
organisms that live in you that are part
of you they're not really parasites they
live saprophytically they live in you
and they complement you they complement
your immune function and they complement
a lot of other things like your ability
to for example get a vaccine and and do
well against a disease like mumps or
or herpes for example so the biome is
extremely important if we continue to
exercise into our older years we watch
our diet and control our fats like
cholesterol ldl hdl the good and the bad
cholesterol and if we look at our
various nutrients as we get older we
will hopefully avoid things like
dementia which is mental decline most
people say oh you know you can lift to
110 but you you you think you're living
back in 1935
and that's not what we want we want you
to keep your mentation going now we have
a thing called epigenetics which i talk
about in the book and you've heard of
epigenetics that's the effect of
environment diet
influences like stress which is probably
the greatest adverse influence on bodily
function
if you can de-stress yourself if you can
have a great diet if you can exercise up
until the point where you're say in your
90s and your legs will continue to
support you
and your mentation stays intact then
you'll get over the 100-year finish line
now that's presuming you don't drink too
much you don't smoke these are all
adverse exogenous influences i call it
if you don't drink and smoke or don't
take illicit drugs
you'll live beyond a hundred there's no
question about it your immune system
really uh depends on
the way you take care of it it
imperceptibly operates daily every
millisecond of the day your immune
system is warding off some infection you
don't even know about
many cancers within your body are being
warded off by your immune system
uh all of these things go on
imperceptibly without people's knowledge
but if you
foster that and and feed that system
your homeostasis as we in medicine call
it you lift to beyond 100.
you know i love that you tackle the
mental side of it too and not just the
typical kind of diet exercise so the
whole how we started you know have more
sex
yes yes just great have you seen any
connection to
you know you're talking about stress so
have you seen any connection to actually
having a great
job or business or purpose or feeling
like what i do is gonna matter because i
think most people wake up most of
america wakes up and drives the job that
they hate and yeah and there is no
you know progress or purpose have you
seen any connection between hey like i
what i do matters it means something to
health and
well
i am not a psychologist or a
psychiatrist but my friends who are in
those fields tell me that yes purposeful
purposeful work where you accomplish
something either writing or you produce
music
or you entertain
the greatest satisfaction comes to
people who get applause and acclimation
from other individuals that's sort of i
look at it like a global sense of
companionship the most important thing
is to have a partner
it could be several partners several
pets whatever makes you feel like you're
contributing and makes you comfortable
in your life
a lot of people lead very stressful
lives they leave by them they live by
themselves uh they barely eat three
meals a day
many of them are chained smokers that's
not what i mean
now there is one factor that i have to
mention and that's immunogenetics and
the immunogenetics means what you've
inherited from your grandparents and
their parents and their parents
generations of people who have say heart
disease or dementia
or other illnesses like myasthenia or an
autoimmune disease like rheumatoid
arthritis
those can be inherited and those can
have an adverse effect on your length of
life
but we can control those now and that's
one of the reasons we're living to a
ripe old age as the quote goes
because we can control pretty much all
diseases and we will be controlling
cancer as i write in the book and the
last part of the book what the future
holds we are controlling cancers with uh
with blockade of t cell function or
training t cells to attack certain
tumors and that sort of thing all of
those things are prolonging life and
increases our longevity but the quality
of life
and the wish to live longer is very very
important so you're right if you do a
job that where you feel you're
contributing that's why a lot of people
volunteer for emergency medical services
and i speak to that because i'm the
medical director of several agencies
volunteers
they go and they volunteer
go out in the middle of the night with
the ambulance and pick people up and
bring them to the hospital that's really
pure altruism but it's also very
important for your mental well-being and
for your feelings of accomplishment
now there are people who volunteer with
the poor you know feeding the poor on
holidays and stuff like that or making
gifts for people who come back from the
armed armed forces for example those are
all things that we add that add value to
our lives
i love it but what do you think
maybe in the past five years you've
learned
that has
been new advice that now you're giving
to patients that maybe you didn't
believe before but now you do
well the first and foremost thing is the
biome which i never really quite
understood
when i was getting my phd in
microbiology i have an md and a phd my
phd was from a professor in philadelphia
who studied gut organisms and all i can
remember is his laboratory had the
foulest smells because he would take
stool
take stool from various patients and he
would look at the organisms in these
various stool samples and now we know
that's really legit stuff we actually do
fecal transplants in some people but his
studies of these organisms was really
extraordinary and he was a
he was on the frontier of what the
microbiome was all about and how
important it is to understand that we
have organisms that live on our skin and
our lungs and our hearts and our brains
even i suspect although i've no data on
that and we have organisms certainly in
the bowel which is that 27 feet of small
intestine that is populated with
trillions of viruses bacteria and
parasites we don't even know about that
but they are very important to our
well-being
so these are the things in the last five
years that's probably one of the
greatest things the second greatest
thing is the effect of the brain and the
immunology of the brain as far as pain
and chronic fatigue goes
i've learned a great deal a lot within
the last five or maybe even less like
two years
about the functions of cytokines or
communication molecules which i go into
in detail in my book those communication
molecules are like radio messages
between police cars the police being the
immune system detective division the
patrolman division and there are these
communications that go on in
milliseconds between various parts of
our body using these chemokines and
cytokines there's now about 250
cytokines and they're also in the brain
and the brain is a privileged site so
you can't get to the brain except
through the choroid plexus at the base
of the brain which is where spinal fluid
goes back and forth between your cord
and the brain tissue itself so that's
all new stuff and that's pretty amazing
stuff when you think about it so the
thing that happens on your leg can be
transmitted to your brain in
milliseconds and your brain can react to
an injury that you have and um i always
wondered about that and these
communication molecules and how they
function
um and then there's things like
endorphins
that we've heard out now there's new
neural hormones like oxytocin and
prolactin i mentioned at the the earlier
part of this uh program
all of these things are new and then
there's molecular biology and we know
best about molecular biology with regard
to crispr crispr is our ability now to
snip genes out and put new genes in to
certain certain parts of the genome and
it's scary for a lot of people because a
lot of people think oh well you know
we're going to take the fetus or we're
going to take the egg and we're going to
make it a male with uh you know with
great big muscles or we're gonna make a
beautiful female with blue eyes we're
gonna create we're gonna do we're gonna
take the god action i think that's what
they call it with this crispr technology
which is wonderful and um and all of
this is all new stuff within the last
five years we're in an exponential phase
of growth as far as biology and medicine
goes
you know i love how
how you're into it you know i think a
lot of people they they uh get to a
certain level and then it's just okay i
know what i know and i'm just gonna keep
doing what i'm doing and not keep
advancing and keep learning and and so
you know
it's amazing all the things that you're
doing um i went and i got my gut
bacteria uh tested
and
i'm wondering how how do we
easily change it so i my test came back
all solid except that i could use some
more acromancia
and at the time i was like what the heck
is that kermit i mean it sounds like the
most complicated word like never heard
of hackerman sia before yeah and so now
i'm now i'm setting up google alerts for
acromancy i'm trying to learn all about
it
how do we actually
change our like if i needed more
acromancia what am i doing to actually
get it
well there are various substances you
can take as probiotics for i can't tell
you that acromancia is one that you can
easily replace but if you eat there are
and i mentioned these in the book if you
eat certain nutrients like um there's a
thing called gut buster gut juice which
you can get in the supermarket
sounds gross doctor bob cheese just
sounds like
[Laughter]
amounts and i wouldn't go near it
um but you know if i treat somebody
chronically with antibiotics and i kill
their microbiome and that happens you
know that's why the indiscriminate use
of antibiotics by a lot of doctors for
things like a viral infection they give
you
penicillin
that's inappropriate and that penicillin
does great damage to your biome so for
example the acromancia you know you can
eat
kimchi various cultures eat fermented uh
soups
for example in russia and in eastern
europe they have a lot of this stuff
they eat all sorts of yogurt do you
remember that georgian village years ago
in the uh in the city of uh like near
tablissi where it was on a mountaintop
where everybody was greater than 140
years of age
those guys
had microbiomes that were like iron i
mean they ate a lot of yogurt they
fermented their own veggies they did all
sorts of things and they kept their
biomes really robust so i think um i
don't know how to re i'm not at the
stage where because i'm not a
nutritionist or anything where i can
tell you how to get your acromancia back
except that prebiotics might do it and
probiotics could certainly add to it
yeah my understanding of prebiotics is
basically giving
a great environment for the bugs to grow
in that's right and that could be very
gassy to a lot of people uh you know
i like your sexy your sex advice better
than the gut juice and gassy food
yeah that's right well i could certainly
say that uh we've given a good message
today so that uh when you're when you're
squeezing hugging and kissing your
either your partner being a man or a
woman that you will uh think uh wow this
is great for my health we always knew it
was sort of great fear
but now we really know it is
yeah and
and what's great is like it's measurable
you know yes
and and uh i think so i've i've been
with
my wife for coming up on 10 years um
later this year and it's easy just to
kind of fall into
your routine and systems and yes yeah
even combining things right like you
talk about going for activities well you
could do that together like yes go for a
walk remember to hold hands while you're
going for the walk exactly exactly and
that's very very important because just
the very act of holding hands increases
the oxytocin in the blood and also the
prolactin levels um and probably other
neural hormones that we don't know much
about
all increase with
gestures of intimacy and that's really
important i'm 41
and so you know we'll still hold hands
after 10 years and my wife commented uh
hey are we still going to do this in our
70s go for walks and hold hands like i
hope so like yeah good yes yes why not
dr bob said to so let's do it
you should
well the book is called immunity strong
yeah boost your natural healing power
and live to a hundred if people want to
grab a copy or or dive deeper into your
world
books on amazon
anywhere else you want them to go
barnes and noble here in the states i
don't know if you have that in canada
any major bookseller should be able
should have the book or be able to get
it i don't know if you have costco in
canada do you have costco
yeah
it's the 2022 selection i think they
picked two books every year the immunity
strong book is one of them so they can
get it in costco as well
i love it and and if people want to dive
further into your world your website or
where do you want them to go oh yeah dr
bob lahita.com the website i'm still
building it as everyone else's i'm sure
you can go on the website and see stuff
and
you can you can see me on tv
periodically
talking about not only the immune system
but other things uh various diseases etc
so no it's um that's the way to find me
and i'd be glad if you send an email to
me i'll be glad to answer you could do
that through my website you can send an
email through the website i'd be glad to
answer you personally if you have any
questions
i love it thank you dr bob for the
insights of time appreciate you and uh
best of luck with the book launch thank
you evan great to be with you
all right take care bye if you want to
see the one-on-one i did with dr steven
gundry check the video right there next
to me i think you'll love it continue to
believe and i'll see you there fruit
juices dramatically increase the risk of
cancer what is one thing that you
believe about energy that most people
don't